while filming today's program we learned
that Elizabeth Warren is ending her
presidential campaign that's why the
earlier stories today didn't yet reflect
that knowledge but now we know Warren is
out Warren had a terrible showing on
Super Tuesday she didn't win a single
state not only on Super Tuesday but in
her entire candidacy in 2020 finished in
third place here in her home state of
Massachusetts behind both Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders currently has 65
delegates according to The Associated
Press and from what we know as of right
now she is not immediately making an
endorsement a lot of speculation that
the one possibility for Bernie Sanders
would be not only for Elizabeth Warren
to get out but to endorse Bernie I don't
know that it's in her interests to
endorse Bernie if she believes Biden is
going to be the nominee and I don't know
that she really is that set on wanting
Bernie to be the nominee by endorsing
Bernie at this point she would
essentially shut herself out from a
possible Biden presidency to the extent
we believe that there may be one so as
of now than the news is no immediate
endorsement the other reason I think she
may not endorse Bernie
um is that it may not make any
difference whatsoever in the sense that
while there are certainly Warren
supporters who have Bernie as their
second choice roughly the same number
even as if six weeks ago had Joe Biden
as their second choice and given the
momentum it simply may not be an
endorsement that actually makes the
difference that some folks think it
might make and for this reason I would
be surprised if Warren endorsed Bernie
Sanders but by the time this clip is
published things are moving very quickly
even that may have happened Elizabeth
Warren out and this changes the numbers
in some states to some degree but you
have to combine it with Michael
Bloomberg exiting as well so if you look
at a state like New York for example
there's no doubt that Warren exiting is
good to some degree for Bernie it may be
just as good for Biden but Bloomberg
exiting where he had a lot of support in
New York that will be significantly good
for Joe Biden and I
expect that to be reflected in the
results so the end of Elizabeth Warren's
campaign we were wondering when it would
happen thought it might happen Tuesday
night or maybe even Wednesday ending up
happening today Thursday and we'll
continue to follow the polling impact
and this means we are going to have that
Bernie versus Biden showdown in a debate
on March 15 and we will talk later in
the show about what that dynamic will be
like as well